[Music]
here at the final four there is probably
one thing that every fan whether a
jayhawk wildcat blue devil or tar heel
can agree upon a trip to new orleans is
not complete without a stop at cafe
dumont french for cafe of the world it
has become just that known globally for
its coffee and beignets which are square
french style donuts served in powdered
sugar still housed in the heart of the
french quarter where it was established
in 1862
cafe du monde has also been a family
affair since the 1940s when the
fernandez family purchased the
restaurant i caught up with jay roman
part of the family's third generation
now savoring the flavor their family
helps bring to new orleans
[Music]
it's the new orleans party
open to all
cafe dumont
it's green and white awning on decatur
street as famous as its lines this lady
would like an order of beignets can you
take care of her for me
[Applause]
thank you which are always worth the
wait come on down here i don't think
this menu is going to make it to the top
that's all right that's why they give
you three you have two more to go when
we get there
two more pieces of pastry and powdered
sugar perfection cafe dumont's signature
beignets do you know how many calories
are in one
i don't think we don't count calories in
new orleans that's who you know we are a
food city and and calories don't count
we check them at the board i like that
true or not the beignets are a french
quarter staple made and served fresh
the recipe basics roll dough cut into
squares tossed into the fryer by hand
then coated in the white stuff is there
a way to make the perfect beignet the
biggest thing is is when you roll it out
and then put it in the oil you want to
make sure the oil is hot enough because
that's what's going to get it to puff up
and the
secret to keeping the powdered sugar at
least until i dump it all over myself
basically on the beignet is just when
they're hot when they're hot you put it
on and if you can sift it you know to do
something to get it on a smooth coat and
then when you're biting the beignet is
don't breathe in or breathe out it's
just kind of hold your breath and go for
it
yep there goes the sugar
how do you not love that
oh my god i know i look ridiculous right
now not at all we like that look
after a few more bites kind of use your
fingers a little bit to separate them i
tried my hands at making some and trying
to keep the shape and found it's not as
easy as it looks put it in but don't put
it in with too much force oil is very
hot
close and then we just just give it a
little push
so afraid of that i mean that's good
that's what i want everybody afraid of
that oil i missed my first free throw i
can do it that's okay you'll do better
yeah you did i think i was a little
afraid all right so this oh my gosh very
close or the third but now i understand
why they're all there you go perfect
you'll get everything you need jay roman
has been surrounded by beignets his
entire life his grandfather hubert
fernandez bought cafe dumond in 1942
it's been their family legacy ever since
i have a 15 month old granddaughter who
is getting ready to eat her first
beignet her mom is you know
making her grow a couple more teeth
before she lets her gather but she will
be taking her first bite of a beignet
shortly i'm thinking about you as a
young kid running around with powdered
sugar all over you this had to be a
dream come true it was perfect we
enjoyed you know it was okay until you
get to the old enough and then they made
you sweep the floor but even working had
its benefits my daughter graduated from
tulane just a few years ago in an
industry known for keeping those in it
away from family at cafe du monde they
continue to be surrounded by it i got to
go to work with dad or i got to go work
with my uncles you know that was
something i looked forward to doing so i
always tried when my kids were growing
up to not tell them this is what they
were going to do you know let them see
for themselves it is something they
wanted and now now they do i have two
children both of them are working in the
business and doing well with it the
family isn't the only thing intertwined
with cafe du monde so is new orleans
itself people talk about new orleans as
the gumbo pot you know a mixture of a
whole lot of things and we're just very
proud to be one of the one of the
ingredients in that pipe with a history
that dates back to 1862
it's no wonder that's when cafe dumont
began as a coffee stand in what's now
the french market the chicory coffee it
served the same you get today chicory is
the root of the endive which is a
lettuce and that is roasted and ground
and mixed with the coffee the original
settlers to new orleans had very short
supplies the trick they used to stretch
their supplies was to add
the endive to the coffee it developed
its own taste in the taste duck why did
your grandfather decide that he had to
buy cafe dumont you know he just sat
across the street and again you got to
remember 1942 this wasn't uh it wasn't a
lot of tourism in new orleans in 1942
but he just had a vision from coffee
stand to cafe to 10 locations around new
orleans there's even merchandise and
shipping nationwide but when in the
crescent city the original decatur
street location is the must-visit spot
not only for tourists one of the times
bill clinton was here in new orleans and
he was getting ready to leave driving my
kids to school and they were on the
radio saying he's late you know but he
must be going for beignets at cafe de
mon with that my cell phone rang and it
was my guy downtown saying the secret
service is here even with the celebrity
status and the growth cafe du monde
remains true to its roots we have one
food product you the beignets that's it
it's really good
we hope so but i mean it is it is our
only food product the cafe is with milk
the beverages for for a number of years
when i was growing up we had coffee and
we had cold milk and over the years
we've expanded a little bit people have
developed taste for iced coffee and
frozen coffee and
but still is a very simple menu is it
tempting in what this world has become
in food to get the gluten-free beignet
or the
no sugar added you get people with
requests all the time for the
gluten-free and can you sell sandwiches
and can you do this and can you do that
why i mean when you do something well
when you continue to do it and and
people seem to enjoy it you know we just
stick with what you do best i think cafe
dumont does that 24 7 364. with the
original location only scheduled to be
closed christmas day and while the doors
have been shut by hurricanes like
katrina and more recently with the
pandemic roman says opening them back up
is also a part of that family tradition
looking at this and having
all these people enjoy them some for the
first time does that ever get old no
never gets old makes it worth getting up
every morning to see everything all the
happy faces of some of the young
children eating their first beignet it
makes it all worthwhile
[Music]
first or 50th i don't know which one i'm
on you guys have your beignets i have
mine i did ask how much powdered sugar
they go through in a week and he said a
couple tons a couple tons but wow so
good they are so good
the only thing that's changed in all
those years dana is the price i remember
when a beignet or three beignets were a
buck and a cup of coffee was a buck and
now i'm i'm sure it's well over that
this coffee is done you know what i
don't remember actually
but they're delicious they're so good i
don't think they're actually that
expensive michelle honestly it's like
two or three bucks now but you know i
always and the lines are outrageous now
i'm sorry about it right but worth it so
worth it
so good okay
thank you